hi welcome back to hannity last week we
saw a disturbing story this time out of
colorado family was removed from a
united airlines flight because their
two-year-old daughter
while she was not wearing a face mask
take a look
um
united did provide a statement to us
regarding the incident saying that the
health and safety of their customers
their highest priority they're also
confirmed the family's not banned from
flying in the future here with more the
parents of that two-year-old removing
the flight
ellie's is with us or ben and also
erhard orbin is with us
well first of all my kids are a little
older a little older than you guys i've
been there
done that am i wrong in thinking
most people want to just help you guys
out in a moment like that because we can
all relate to that
ali oh yeah absolutely we've gotten so
much
um support that's actually how this
video got so viral
because people just couldn't believe
what happened to us yeah and
and i'm looking you know earhard you're
you're there you
it's like you're trying to like okay
i'll try and keep her covered don't
worry i'll work on it
then they just say get the hell off the
plane how did that go
you know it was very very confusing for
me as well we were we were allowed to
board the plane and then once we sat
down a supervisor came up to us and
asked us to de-plane
and uh the entire time we were trying to
keep the mask on her we kept switching
back and forth between elise and i
and the flight wasn't even that full and
what you said before was very
interesting that
nobody else on the plane actually said
anything
i know if i was on a plane and this
situation was happening i would have
stood up and said something as well
you know i'm watching you two and you
guys are trying to follow the rules
ellie's
it's a two-year-old little girl you're
doing everything humanly possible
i'm sure you had an important trip then
i heard that you couldn't even get your
luggage back
at least tell us about it
yeah so after we got kicked off the
plane um
they proceeded to tell us that we
weren't going to get our two bags which
had everything in it
and our car seat then they pulled back
the plane because i mean i almost had a
heart attack we lived two hours from the
airport so if we didn't have a car seat
i don't even know how we would have
gotten back so they did pull the car
seat off
but not our bags so we had to wait uh
more than 24 hours for our bags to
arrive
so we we totally missed our trip okay so
you missed your trip
you had to fight to get the car seat so
you can drive your daughter home
and then your luggage goes i i think
your destination was new york if i
remember
yes newark yeah yeah maybe listen
don't come to new york it's not the
greatest it's not the safest place they
cut a billion dollars off the police
i don't know if it's a bad idea you know
i i'm just wondering in moments like
that
because i think if anyone that's had
kids
you're looking at this cute kid it's
impossible
to keep a mask on a two-year-old it's
just impossible you're trying the best
you can
and you know i'm watching you as the dad
you're there you know you're holding it
i got her i got her i'll keep her and if
the plane's not full
why don't they just say okay we're gonna
cordon off this section of the plane for
you guys do the best you can we'll get
you there
and and get your daughter there safely
hopefully an hour into the flight she
falls asleep right
yeah that would have been best case
scenario i think that would have been
something that could have been done
since the flight was not full
but it was not done i mean we we the
flight attendant that
that we talked to initially so basically
none of the flight attendants spoke to
us
after we boarded the plane after that it
was just
the actual supervisor who kicked us off
the plane so
there could have been a different
solution but there wasn't and i we
really feel like we were just singled
out in the situation
i hope they give you guys like a free
year of travel did they offer you
anything at least
you're trying now i'm dreaming right of
course not anyway your daughter's
adorable
i'm sorry that happened to you guys
thanks for being with us more